hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game uh from the semi-finals of the
speed chase Championship it's nikal
sarin versus hikarnakamura and this is
one of the games that you guys started
suggesting as soon as it finished but I
I would have shown it uh even if no one
suggested it as it's uh absolutely
incredible and for those of you who are
maybe just tuning in at uh no uh what is
happening here well like I said this is
the semi-final of the speeches
Championship uh nikal defeated uh Anish
giri uh what he barely defeated him with
15 to 14 then he defeated dingler in the
quarterfinal 17-9 and now he faces
Hikaru in the semi-final who defeated uh
David paravian with 19 and a half to
seven and a half and eleven arunyan with
15 and a half to eight and a half and
the winner of this match will face the
winner of the the other semi-final match
Magnus Carlsen versus Maxime bashiro La
Graf uh let's check it out it's quite
the game uh uh uh nikal opens with
Knight to F3 he goes for foreignty
opening with Knight to F6 by Hikaru C4
E6 Knight to C3 and D5 so the English
opening is on the board the so-called
Hedgehog we have E3 and pawn to C5 we
have characters captures D4 and now
Knight to C6 so all been played before
nothing new here Bishop to B5 uh and the
bishop to D6 uh we have castles and now
usually uh black will just Castle here
and there are uh plenty of games where
this happened but here we have C
captress on D4 and this has only only
been played a handful of times e
captures and E4 we have Castles by black
and now there is a game where Bishop to
G4 was played a bishop to G5 will sleep
but here uh we have H3 by nihal and it
is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game uh Hikaru goes to H6
takes away the G5 Square from any house
pieces with Rook to E1 and now Rook the
E8 offering a rook trade and now Bishop
captures on C6 getting rid of one of the
defense understood the E5 Square he now
wants the uh get hit hard to play B
captures on C6 and put a knight on E5
and Hikaru can do this or if he doesn't
want to do that he can First Trade Rooks
with check and then pick up the bishop
Hikaru doesn't mind the Knight on E5 he
plays B captures on C6 Knight to the E5
and now Hikaru even trades Bishop
captures on E5 which is something you
usually don't do ever as this Pawn now
on E5 is just a monster guarding the F6
Square so you can never have a knight on
F6 and could be a bit difficult for for
him to defend but he knows what he's
doing Knight to D7 font F4 now defending
D5 pawn and the bishop to B7 with King
to H2 and now Pawn to A6 with Pawn to B4
by nihal saying okay we didn't play C5
you're not playing it now but Hikaru
says I was just waiting for you to play
B4 so I can undermine it with Ponte A5
and okay B captures an A5 with Queen
captures on A5 now attacking the Knight
and C3 and Bishop the D2 We have Pawn to
D4 Knights the E4 attacking the queen
here and queen to D5 beautifully
centralizing the queen on D5 and now at
some point Hikaru will play C5 open up
this diagonal and he will try to
Checkmate to the white king so here
Knight to D6 attacking the rook and the
bishop and Hikaru just plays Ponta C5
now this is the way to go if you try
something like Rook The Rook the B8 then
Queen G4 and you can pretty much resign
here if if let's say C5 now uh then it
just Knights to F5 attacking the G7 Pawn
threatening Checkmate and also Knights
the seven the threat of this Royal Fork
uh will force you to end the game and of
course the queen here covers against
Queen captures on G2 Checkmate so uh
Hikaru plays the only move he has
available that is Pawn to C5 and now uh
nihal doesn't unnecessarily just capture
the bishop he continues development
Queen to G4 and Hikaru says nope you're
not getting that Knight to F5 Pawn to H5
now he wants uh well he would like nihal
to capture on H5 so he can just
Checkmate him with Queen captures on G2
but of course that's not happening Queen
to G3 and now Rook to E6 preparing Rook
to G6 to add another attacker to go for
that G2 pawn and the problem is you
cannot play F5 here F5 here is a trick
Hikaru was trying to was really trying
to bet nihal in because if this happened
then Queen to A3 wins the game you
cannot move the queen away from the
defense of the g-pawn and if you try
Queen G5 then look at this Rook captures
on D6 Pawn captures and now just F6 and
if Queen G6 now we're gonna play Knight
to f8 and the queen can no longer remain
on the G file you could try Rook to E8
okay the Knight cannot move now but not
just a queen captures and D6 with check
and now you win the G3 Square for your
Rook so King G1 let's say Rook to G3 and
that's it the queen is saying also the
G2 Pawn is hanging and you resign here
so really a brutal line and the Hikaru
uh fine uh spotting this with Rook D6 is
just um uh absolutely brilliant
especially since this is three plus one
uh Blitz but nikal also also picking up
on it is incredible uh he goes Knight
captures on B7 we have Queen captures on
B7 and now Pawn to F5 now this is
definitely playable Ponte H4 uh trying
to remove the defender of the E5 Pawn if
Queen captures an H4 then uh Hikaru can
capture on E5 so Queen to F4 not Rook e
back to E8 we have Pawn to F6 and Hikaru
just plays Knight to f8 he doesn't care
about any uh capture sun on G6 he will
put a knight on G6 and he will be very
happy and if Queen to G5 threatening
Checkmate you again play exactly that
and now if E6 looks scary because you
cannot capture an E6 but now just Pawn
to C4 and you don't really care about
this if captures on G7 even C3 and you
just continue pushing if if ecap person
F7 Queen will capture an F7 and
everything's fine so after Knight to a
fate Queen captures an H4 by nihal uh
and not Knight the G6 Hikaru attacks his
queen queen to G3 and now Queen to D5
centralizing the queen once again uh
Bishop to F4 defending the E5 pawn and
now Pawn to D3 now Hikaru starts pushing
his pass Pawn upon the H4 we have rooked
the A4 attacking the bishop here and
pawn to H5 yeah if you didn't play Rook
day 4 then after H5 you resign because
the Knight cannot move otherwise you
just get checkmated so this was the only
way to do it Rook captures an F4 H
characters on G6 and now Rook the F5 uh
once again putting pressure on this E5
Pawn but now nihal finds the incredible
a moment that I've used for the
thumbnail and that is Pawn to E6 and
this is absolutely uh stunning when was
the last time you saw three connected
pawns on the on the sixth rank I mean it
and with black absolutely nothing to
play for here uh for example if you play
G captures
um or well there's really nothing uh and
the E6 was an absolute must like
captures here captures here did nothing
just to give you an example okay this
obviously does nothing but even if this
check is given Queen characters on F7
and okay we can even show uh what would
happen if this is played uh then you
just play F captures and G6 and if Queen
captures then you play Rook F captures
on E5 and the white can never do
anything here black is completely
winning especially if you go captures
then captures uh the A1 Rook is hanging
but okay you could play King H3 saying
if you capture on A1 I'm gonna capture
on E8 uh but just rookie six you kick
away the queen and then you can pick up
the Rook so it's uh not much to play for
so instead I have to Rook F5 E6 this
brilliancy by nihal yeah and now Rook
the H5 with check King to G1 and queen
to D4 check and here uh there is only
one winning move and it's uh quite a
tricky one uh because uh well uh you you
have to uh you you have to find a very
particular idea in order to win this
because you will have to go into the end
game to win this so feel free to pause
the video and try to spot the winning
idea here for nihal uh while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting that
you have to mess up a black spawn
structure and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it is Queen to E3
uh interestingly you cannot play Queen
to F2 and uh even worse you can't play
King to F1 then Rook H1 is mate in one
uh but if you play uh Queen to F2 then
you allow black to just trade queens and
go for this Rook to F5 check and now
it's very easy to defend with black
you're gonna play Rook captures on E6
and after real characters and E6 F
captures an E6 and not F7 check King to
f8 and now it seems like uh you might be
able to play this but let's say A4 you
you start advancing the pawn and uh well
blacks black spawns are also just as
strong and you will not be able to do
this but the main idea is that now after
Rook the B1 uh you cannot play this uh
because let's say upon the C4 you have
Rook the B8 check and die after King D7
you don't have f8 uh Queen because the
Rook is an F5 that's very very important
take into consideration so that's why
Queen to E3 solves all of your problems
because now if you trade Queens then
after Rook captures and Rook captures an
E6 it's not the same because after
captors captures F7 checking to f8 and
Rook the B1 The Rook is not an F5 and
this is now Unstoppable just Rook to f8
checked and that's it even if you try
Rook to F5 now it doesn't really do
anything because you're just gonna go
Rook to B8 check King the E7 rooked the
E8 with check you're gonna kick away the
the the the king king to D7 or D6
doesn't really matter and f8 queen uh
now will force a capture and then a rook
remains into the game but yeah uh very
very complicated stuff and also the
problem in in that line uh uh sorry for
not finishing it when The Rook was on F5
just in case you were wondering if you
go for the exact same idea of Rook to E8
with Chuck King the D7 and f8 queen it's
not a problem because after Rook
captures and I fade Rook captures
there's Pawn to D2 and The Rook cannot
stop the two connected past pawns and
that's the difference between this and
the line with Queen to E3 where you
cannot trade queens and uh as the
position is winning and uh after Rook
captures and E6 the move that he car
played now just Queen captures on D4 the
only winning move uh which ruins the
correspond structure and ensures that
the following end game is winning for
white so C captures on D4 Rook captures
and E6 F captures F7 with check King to
f8 and now Rook to B1 and he was in this
position and move 40 that Hikaru
Nakamura resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so it's uh
similar like in that line but now when
you play Rook the F5 the pawns are
doubled and now this is more than enough
Rook to be checking is seven Rook to E8
with checking the seven you will bring
the queen into the game and now after
you trade you don't have to connect it
past bonds and now after D2 there's Rook
to F1 you are not in time to advance the
you know a non-existent pawn to defend
this pawn and then bring a Queen into
the game so really really complicated
stuff and it's incredible what these
guys are doing it's three plus one uh
time control uh absolutely absolutely
incredible uh so yeah a big win for uh
for nihal uh in this um uh semi-final of
the of the speeches Championship he's
still losing uh both in uh the five plus
one and the three plus one section but
at the time of me recording this he uh
he he lowered his uh uh uh well he
lowered hikaru's lead uh to only two
points and uh they're still bullets so
we'll see if he will be able to bounce
back and maybe even beat uh Hikaru and I
just realized I forgot
[Music]
uh update hikaru's rating I didn't
forget the updated uh I just uh hid it
under his profile photo so there you
have it I know some of you will be
saying in the comments but there's no
rating for Hikaru so there you have it
now there is uh so yeah that's the game
big congratulations to nihal on this
spectacular Victory this uh position
here alone I mean uh absolutely
incredible with the three pawns here but
finding all of those ideas and realizing
that you have to double black spawns in
order to win the end game in three plus
one absolutely stunning and that's why
both nihal and Hikaru are uh two I
believe of the highest rated players on
on chess.com in in Blitz uh sure uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank Timothy Rosa and
Chris Robert Picard sapon Bhatia Sarah
Hamilton and Jonathan Hiroshi uh Hiroshi
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful match uh
until it finishes uh thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day